so when you look at the whales you take
people who've got more than a thousand
bitcoin and you take out the exchanges
people that we know have the exchange
wallets uh it looks like the whales are
going absolute bonkers and buying
bitcoin right now uh and soaking up
whatever they can buy
yeah like so if you look at this invite
i know in the in the chart i put in
there that that you have up on the
screen it's kind of zoomed in but if you
go back to like mid-may um wales did a
lot of the selling on the way down um i
think a lot of that this is a whole side
thing but i think a lot of that had to
do with like some arbitrage
opportunities that closed um because
that kind of aligned with where we saw
um the number of whales and whales
holdings drop off but yeah since like
mid late uh july you started to see
whales you know pretty aggressively
buying and as you mentioned like what
we're looking at here is all the
entities um so this is forensically
clustered addresses which are what
entities are um and then you're
filtering out as you said exchanges and
then also like grayscale the purpose etf
also qbtc um and so you're just
basically getting the raw uh
you know whale balance and so what you
see here is that um since july 17th
which is uh two months ago whales have
added 184 699 btc which is roughly eight
point eight billion dollars once again
using that that 48 000 uh dollar bitcoin
as that's the reference for that
when you look at the asol it remind
everyone what asol ends up actually
being and how you look at this and then
what is this chart telling us
yeah so what we're looking at here is
we're trying to track the age of the
coins that are moving and so there's a
couple ways you can look at this i just
decided to throw an acell because i
hadn't put that chart in the newsletter
for a while
but you want to kind of use all these
metrics in tandem so
um for example we have like our spin
output age bands uh our spend volume age
bands coin days destroyed dormancy
liveliness and each of these different
metrics have a different purpose so
for example like a sol is just the
average of all the spent um outputs on a
given day but there's no weight given to
it by volume so you know if if you have
what appears to be high spending from
older coins
you need to also look at the volume of
which they're selling because if they're
selling like .001 btc no who cares right
but if you're seeing the volume of of um
and that's where you look at the spent
volume age bands
and and also you can look at like point
days destroyed um you can see the volume
of um older coins is perhaps increasing
or decreasing and then look at is is
that in correlation with um like the the
acell or your spent output age bands
which are literally just looking at the
average
or
the average in case of ace hole but also
spent output age bands you're just
looking at the amount of spent outputs
on a given day so you know nuance
yada yada but it's just saying you need
to use these different age-related
metrics in tandem um but overall the
conclusion here is um just the fact that
long-term holders are sitting tight
right we're seeing declining in in the
age of the coins that are being spent on
each you know on on every given day over
the last week or so um and so you see
that in tandem across you know across
the board and all these age-related
spending metrics and that's just the
kind of point i was trying to get out
here so a lot of the spending is coming
from these younger coins
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]